et avec nous pour ce club parce qu'elle
tournait bonjour Pascal bonjour merci
d'être là
merci d'être avec nous directeur délégué
à l'institut Harris Interactive et
Quentin et de retour pour cette matinale
dans bonjour à tous évidemment de la
réforme des retraites dans l'examen se
poursuit cette semaine au Sénat en
examen qui s'est tendu depuis le vote de
l'article 7 sur le report de l'âge qui a
lancé une guerre de procédure entre la
gauche et la droite sénatoriale et la
majorité présidentielle qui s'accuse
mutuellement d'obstruction et puis à la
fin de ce club on va parler d'autre
chose que de la réforme des retraites on
fêtera les 30 ans de la Twingo une
voiture qui a marqué les Français et qui
comptent des fans qu'on ira rencontrés
d'abord en regardant ensemble
l'actualité dans nos régions
[Musique]
et l'actualité dans nos régions du côté
de Metz où on retrouve Hervé Boggio
bonjour Hervé merci d'être avec nous
chef du service reportage aux
Républicain Lorrain Hervé avec vous on
va parler d'un autre sujet on va parler
nucléaire puisque vous proposez à vos
lecteurs un grand dossier sur cette
question dans votre région
bonjour à toutes et à tous oui on
consacre notre dossier régional du jour
à la filière nucléaire qui est très
importante en grand test et
singulièrement en Moselle du fait
notamment la présence de la centrale de
Cattenom alors souvenez-vous Belfort
février 2022 président de la République
prononce un discours qui a qui définit
les objectifs neutralité carbone du pays
redéfinis au passage notre politique
énergétique et relance du même coup le
programme nucléaire français ouvrant la
voie à la construction de 6 à 14 EPR de
nouvelle génération un défi économique
et technologique immense avec en région
un challenge absolument colossal celui
des compétences et donc de la formation
du CAP au Bac +8 sur tout le spectre
donc alors pensez l'ambition politique
implique pour la filière la création de
150000 emplois sur 10 ans à l'échelle du
pays soit pour le grand est selon les
estimations 1000 à 1500 postes par an
sur la même période alors pour relever
le gant alors même que l'industrie toute
filière confondue peine déjà à recruter
une université des métiers du nucléaire
a été créée à Paris en 2021 qui doit
permettre de fédérer de catalyser les
initiatives en grandes il y a trois
établissements secondaires et
supérieures qui sont particulièrement
engagés dans cette dynamique à
Thionville en Moselle tout près de
katnum justement un Haute-Marne et en
Meurthe-et-Moselle un énorme défi donc
je disais
aussi par la mise en place qui qui doit
être sous tendue par la mise en place de
stratégies adaptées pour rechercher et
séduire les talents un enjeu qui était
toute cette semaine au coeur de la
semaine des des métiers du nucléaire qui
s'achève aujourd'hui à Nancy et qui a
mobilisé non seulement des cadres
d'EDF mais aussi ceux de Pôle Emploi
nombre d'industriels et de pas mal
d'acteurs de la formation et de
l'apprentissage une sorte de branle-bas
de combat alors même qu'il n'est pas
encore pour l'heure en tout cas question
d'une implantation européenne dans la
région justement Hervé à l'avenir
quelles sont les conditions pour qu'un
EPS puisse voir le genre en Lorraine
pour le moment c'est pas cet horizon là
qui qui s'avance mais bon les six
premiers réacteurs annoncés par Emmanuel
Macron à l'horizon 2035 environ tes
fléchés sur panli en Normandie et
Gravelines dans le Nord un troisième
site à toutes les chances de voir le
jour dans la vallée du Rhône mais en
grand test on baisse pas les bras et on
essaye de lever le nez au-dessus de cet
horizon là justement pour faire pour
faire valoir les les atouts qui sont
ceux de qui sont ceux de la région et il
y en a comme un panier et à Gravelines
quatre noms accueille déjà une centrale
ce qui toutes les études le montrent un
croissantiblement le seuil de tolérance
des populations riveraines aux nouveaux
projets le surcroît l'écosystème
industriel local est déjà en place et
EDF a anticipé dispose déjà d'emprise
foncière très importante autour du site
de Cattenom un gros bémol toutefois le
site est situé à quelques kilomètres à
vol d'oiseau des frontières allemandes
et Luxembour geoises deux voisins dans
les opinions publiques sont très très
sensibles sur ce dossier et notamment
sur les questions de sûreté autant dire
que les annonces de la SN cette semaine
sur la nouvelle fissure de fatigue
thermique cette fois-ci qui a été
détecté à 4 nobles après ponly et bien
les inquiets particulièrement donc un
dossier qui reste ouvert mais qui n'est
pas gagné merci beaucoup ou Hervé c'est
à dire dans le Républicain Lorrain on
regarde la une nucléaire le regain
d'énergie c'est à la une du républicain
Laurent merci beaucoup Hervé Boggio
d'avoir été avec nous on va évidemment
parler de la réforme des retraites c'est
l'actualité de la semaine au Sénat ça va
durer au moins jusqu'à dimanche minuit
Quentin et les sénateurs le disent tous
il y aura un avant et un après réforme
des retraites absolument on a atteint un
niveau de tension électrique comme ça
entre la droite et la gauche
sénatorielle qui est rarement atteint
dans l'hémicycle du Sénat alors certes
le Sénat n'est jamais tombé tout au long
de ces 8 jours que l'on a eu dans
l'outrans des débats qu'on avait pu voir
à l'Assemblée nationale mais le niveau
d'énervement est maximal sur cette
réforme des retraites ce qui se joue
depuis mardi soir lorsque les sénateurs
ont commencé à examiner l'article 7
celui sur les 64 ans c'est plus ni moins
qu'une véritable guérilla parlementaire
dans l'hémicycle toutes les armes du
règlement sont utilisées amendement
explication de vote réécriture de l'AR
ticle par la commission sous amendement
article 38 qui vient contraindre le
nombre de prises de parole sur un
amendement alors certes c'est poli et
respectueux dans les échanges mais ça
n'en reste pas moins tendu écouter un
tout petit exemple c'était hier
après-midi en séance c'est pas la
présidence qui parle c'est la présidence
de la droite on dirait mais bon
[Musique]
on voit en tout cas
vous pouvez demander une suspension de
séance je
reprends la parole monsieur chanterelle
monsieur chanterelle s'il vous plaît
je reprends la parole jamais vous
pourrez dire ça jamais tant mieux
pour tout le monde merci alors
maintenant je vous demande de faire
votre intervention
d'essayer de garder le calme
alors
votre intimidation ne marchera pas merci
je sais que vous c'est je sais que vous
essayez de nous baïonner de nous
intimider de plus plusieurs depuis hier
dans la totalité du règlement monsieur
Chantrel il y a un article 95 qui dit
très clairement que toute provocation
toute atteinte à la présidence de séance
entraîne la censure voir l'exclusion du
Sénat
voilà une menace d'activer un
infiltrément qu'on connaît pas du tout
au Sénat imaginez censurer ou faire
sortir un sénateur c'est quelque chose
que on imagine pas ici à la Chambre
haute et c'est un exemple un ce qui
s'est joué hier après-midi dans une
myriade parfois on arrête de parler du
fond de la réforme pendant des dizaines
et des dizaines de minutes voir
plusieurs heures pour ces sharper autour
du Règlement du Sénat tout cela fait
dire au chef de fil des socialistes
qu'il y aura un avant et un après
écoutez Patrick canard à notre micro
il y aura un avant et un après article 7
de cette loi scélérate de réforme des
retraites de notre pays
pour le cylin notamment parce que c'est
la première fois que la majorité sur
notoriale au taux de son président ce
que je regrette autour de Monsieur
brutal Retailleau
utilise les amendements prioritaires qui
font tomber de nos amendements qui
utilisent l'article 38 c'est à dire que
un vote pour un vote contre et on arrête
le débat donc on clôture le débat qui
utilise l'article 42 il vient d'être
utilisé pour nous empêcher de faire des
explications de vote je le regrette nous
le regrettons parce que c'est vrai que
cette chambre a été habituée à respect
très profond pour son opposition je n'ai
plus le cas aujourd'hui voilà c'est
interview à réaliser juste après bien
les débats autour de l'article 7 et le
vote par le Sénat alors à droite on
assume les LR et les cent triste veulent
aller au bout de l'examen du texte d'ici
dimanche soir minuit quitte à utiliser
donc toutes les armes règlement écoutez
Hervé Marseille pour les centristes si
vous voulez on peut aussi partir comme
ça on les laisse tout seul et puis tout
va bien non je veux dire la gauche n'a
pas voulu qu'on débatte à l'Assemblée
elle s'oppose au débat au Sénat nous
utilisons le règlement pour pouvoir
exprimer notre différence et nous nous
souhaitons qu'il y ait un débat que le
texte enrichi et que nous votions voilà
les interviews réalisés pendant nos
éditions spéciales puisqu'on suit ça
depuis la salle des conférences il reste
980 amendements examinés à l'heure on se
parle et le temps presse puisque les
sénateurs devraient avoir fini dimanche
à minuit de quoi donc tendre encore les
échanges d'ici là et on va Pascal et
Jean Daniel les échanges qui se sont
tendus depuis mardi depuis l'examen de
l'article 7 alors avant le début de la
Réforme on disait beaucoup qu'au Sénat
ça allait se passer dans une ambiance
feutrée beaucoup plus calme qu'à
l'Assemblée est-ce que finalement cette
réforme des retraites elle a un peu
réveillé le volcan Sénat qui était
peut-être un plan d'orange
moi ce qui me frappe surtout c'est que
on n'a jamais autant entendu parler vous
en avez cité un certain nombre de
d'articles de règlement donc moi surtout
ce que je vois c'est du ça des manières
les institutions de la Cinquième
République tiennent mais la vraie
question est de tout le monde le dit un
peu la légitimité qui qui peut exister
entre d'un côté les amants les
institutions le Parlement et la
légitimité de la rue et là en chinois je
me pose la question est-ce qu'on voit
bien qu'on va chercher dans les dans les
tiroirs de tout tout artifice de
procédure pour faire vraiment passer à
tout prix ce texte mais donc finalement
on va avoir un texte si il est voté qui
va passer en force mais est-ce que
aujourd'hui ce système cette façon de
faire est-elle adaptée véritablement
voilà à la situation actuelle du pays
moi c'est vraiment la question que je
pose aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est
vraiment adapté et et pas aller à
l'encontre d'une demande aujourd'hui de
démocratie d'horizontalité voilà je pose
la question Jean Daniel ce que vous
arrivez à savoir ce qu'on pense les
Français là-dessus en fait on remarque
non seulement le Sénat mais également
l'Assemblée nationale et en fait depuis
ces 8 derniers mois il y a globalement
une place du Parlement qui est une place
quasiment inoccupée depuis la création
de la Cinquième République et on aurait
pu s'attendre en fait à ce que ce soit
l'Assemblée en fait l'ensemble la
lumière mais on voit que quand même
globalement les débats la nature des
débats pas uniquement en fait la
question des amendements ou autre mais
même le fond du débat qui peut être
porté marque et relayée et même si je
peux me permettre dépasse le cas de
Public Sénat et voilà pas être entendu
de la part des des citoyens quand ils
vont être amenés à s'informer à travers
d'autres ressources d'informations ce
qui ce que ce qu'on trouve intéressant
également c'est que le bruit médiatique
malgré tout un effet et autour de l'idée
que il y a eu une confrontation très
forte de plus sur la forme que sur le
fond à l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat
au moins même s'il y a eu ces quelques
derniers jours en fait des artifices qui
ont été utilisés de la part des uns des
autres mais qu'on a quand même pu avoir
en fait un débat de fond des
présentation et que le temps qui a été
passé si je me trompe pas à peu chose
près en tout cas sur les premiers
articles a été le même consacré à
l'Assemblée et au Sénat mais l'image
globale n'a pas été exactement la même
mais avec la perception qu'on était
quand même peut-être un peu plus sur des
débats de fonds que d'affrontement entre
guillemets stérile au Sénat ça veut dire
que ce qui se passe cette semaine au
Sénat est-ce que ça correspond à ce
qu'attendent les Français du débat
parlementaire ça veut dire que
globalement quand on les interroge d'une
manière générale même les électeurs qui
situent le plus à gauche sur l'échiquier
politique sont pas forcément sur
l'obstruction systématique et sans
entrer sans les débats aujourd'hui qui
vont traverser la nuque d'un côté ou les
organisations politiques et les
organisations syndicales de l'autre on a
quand même envie d'entendre ce que
peuvent être soit les
contre-propositions soit les arguments
et que lorsqu'on a le sentiment qu'on
est dans une forme de bataille de cour
de récréation si vous permettez
l'expression globalement ça a quand même
passionne un peu moins les Françaises et
les Français même ceux qui sont les plus
proposer aujourd'hui à la réforme
Eric Coquerel qui était notre invité
juste avant parlait d'une crise de
régime est-ce qu'on est dans une crise
de régime Pascal c'est ce que je disais
un petit peu tout à l'heure c'est que on
voit bien qu'encore une fois les
institutions la Cinquième République par
rapport à d'autres pays la tienne
véritablement encore une fois on voit
toutes les toutes les artifices de
procédure qui sont qui sont invoqués
enfin utilisés donc on va bien qu'il y a
voilà on peut faire passer a priori un
texte puisque même la gérer l'arme
l'arme définitive on le sait c'est le
49-3 que peut être actionné par par la
majorité après
quand une fois est-ce que est-ce que
c'est adapté à l'époque est-ce que c'est
adapté on voit bien aussi quand même
toute la mobilisation sociale est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut véritablement
gouverner contre la rue c'est vrai que
c'est étranché par le passé oui les
gouvernements sont passés en force il
citer tout à l'heure Nicolas Sarkozy en
2010 mais aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est
encore possible vu l'état de pays vu de
tension dans lequel où se trouve
aujourd'hui le pays moi c'est une
question que je pose je me suis pas sûr
est-ce qu'on est dans une crise régime
j'en ai et
Eric Coquerel il disait il va falloir
changer et changer de régime changer les
institutions est-ce que c'est aussi la
vie des Français ou est-ce qu'ils sont
attachés à la Cinquième République et à
nos institutions et est-ce que ce qui se
passe en ce moment au Parlement peut
changer leur opinion globalement ça
marche et quand on interroge les
Français ils disent que ça marche et
quand vous interrogez là pour le coup
plus précisément sur l'Assemblée
nationale que sur le Sénat ils ont eu le
sentiment que ben il y a pas eu
forcément au cours de ces derniers mois
de situation de blocage électrique le
vote un budget des lois qui ont pu être
amenés à passer un travail parlementaire
qui s'est effectué donc on n'est pas
forcément aujourd'hui dans cette
situation où ce qui est pouvait se
passer par exemple en 1958 appelé à
considérer en tout cas d'un point de vue
d'opinion de manière urgente de revoir
ce que peut être nos institutions est-ce
que dans un même élan on a le sentiment
qu'il y a une forme de décorrélation
entre ce qui se passe dans l'opin
on voit bien que tout converge vers lui
le
Eric Coquerel le dit tout à l'heure mais
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui c'est très
fort on va pas dire que ça va être une
réforme borne une réforme Olivier du
socle c'est une réforme d'Emmanuel
Macron donc on voit bien qu'il a créé
une situation de face à face entre la
rue et lui donc là c'est là où je dis et
donc on voit bien que au niveau d'un
parlementaire même si le texte risque
peut-être de passer enfin on le verra
l'avenir le dira mais on voit bien que
finalement le le jeu se joue vraiment
entre de la rue et lui et donc on le
voit bien il refuse de d'ouvrir la porte
de l'Élysée au syndicat ce qui pose
aussi peut-être question mais si on
arrive là c'est que justement bah c'est
là où je pense que bah il a joué un peu
avec le feu c'est la manière sur cette
volonté de verticalité à outrance on va
revenir sur la teneur des débats au
Sénat et sur ce qui s'y passe on a
entendu Quentin avec vous tout à l'heure
la gauche qui reproche à la droite
sénatoriale de trop accélérer le débat
on va écouter la réponse de de la droite
sénatoriale on va écouter Gérard Larcher
c'est-à-dire soir sur notre antenne et
Bruno Retailleau sur LCI
l'opposition c'est très largement
exprimée sur le seul article 7 et le
premier amendement de suppression entre
les paroles sur arctique et les
présentations d'amendement 124
interventions je rappelle qu'il y a 348
sénateurs et que les groupes
rassemblés les trois groupes qui
s'opposent qui sont 91 donc
pardonnez-moi des baillons comme ça ça
permet beaucoup de s'exprimer il y a une
telle obstruction toutes les heures qui
passent la gauche dépose ce qu'on
appelle des sous amendements c'est
ridicule c'est l'inverse voyez du
parlementarisme et on le voit Pascal on
est dans des accusations mutuelle bien
sûr oui tout à fait les débats au Sénat
tout au long de la semaine et qui sont
même en train de les bloquer puisque
hier soir les débats se sont fortement
lisés c'est vrai que la question qu'on
peut se poser c'est ce qu'on va Avaton
arriver au vote donc j'écris comprendre
que Bruno Retailleau demandait une
extension de 24 heures si je m'abuse de
des débats donc c'est vrai qu'on voit
bien que le c'est peut-être pas si
facile que cela de que le vote soit que
le texte pardon soit voté et je dirais
que si le vote si pardon décidément le
vote si le texte n'est pas voté donc ça
veut dire ce sera la CMP qui sera j'irai
mettre du jeu alors même si encore une
fois d'un point de vue légal juridique
tout est raccord bien sûr mais je pose
encore le la question de est-ce que
c'est pas un souci démocratique de se
dire qu'un texte aussi déterminant soit
finalement gérer voter en CMP que donc
cette députés et cette sénateurs
imaginez
imaginez pour le français lambda se dire
que voilà ça va être fait à huis clos
donc ça peut donner matière à toutes
sortes de de théorie je dirais
tout ce qu'on veut enfin vous voyez je
pense que pour la démocratie ce n'est
pas bon ouais et c'est ce que dit un peu
Bruno Retailleau Jean-Daniel Levy que du
coup ça nourrirait l'anti
parlementarisme et que le Parlement le
Sénat notamment se ferait à rak-kiri
c'est dans ce sens que vont les Français
aussi
l'aspiration la transparence dont
parlait Pascal est absolument indéniable
et croissante et on a même parlé tout à
l'heure en fait de la réforme des
institutions lorsqu'on interroge donc on
passerait sur la réforme des
institutions tout ce qui peut renvoyer
peu auproux à une forme de démocratie
directe
les publicités on avait réalisé il y a
un an une très grosse enquête pour le
magazine challenge et on voyait bien en
fait que l'aspiration ou à la
possibilité de pouvoir démettre un élu à
la possibilité de pouvoir mettre en
place un référendum d'initiative
citoyenne à la possibilité de pouvoir
avoir une forme de quelque chose qui se
rapproche du mandat impératif et pas
forcément du mandat représentatif tel
qu'il est en tout cas actuellement dans
la culture de nos institutions traverser
extrêmement manifestement nos
compatriotes mais tout ceci s'inscrit
dans un continuum d'opinion assez
anciens ou globalement on a la
perception que une fois qu'on a élu les
responsables politiques ceci en fait
s'exonère de leur responsabilité ou de
leurs engagements après alables et que
dans ce contexte là il faut qu'il puisse
y avoir des formes de corde de rappel et
tout ce qui renvoie d'une manière ou
d'une autre à une forme de démocratie
directe permettrait à leurs yeux de
mieux contrôler les élus dans l'exercice
de leur mandat après juste pour prendre
le point de vue de la droite et du
centre ils disent qu'il vote une réforme
des retraites au budget de la sécurité
sociale depuis 2018 et en l'occurrence
cette réforme là avec la mesure d'âge à
64 ans et l'accélération de la réforme
Touraine donc Bruno Retailleau dit que
ils sont légitimes à voter cette réforme
parce qu'ils sont eux transparents sur
le fait qu'ils soutiennent une telle
réforme depuis au moins quatre ans on
l'a le temps fort de cette semaine
c'était le vote de cet article 7 sur le
report de l'âge légal de départ on va
voir ce qu'on a dit Olivier du socle le
ministre en charge de la réforme c'est à
votre micro quand on
est-ce que vous dites merci à la
majorité de la droite et du centre vous
qui parliez d'une réforme de gauche avec
200 une voix pour essentiellement les
voies des LRS je dis merci à tous les
sénateurs qui ont à la fois participé au
débat de la droite qui ont soutenu cette
réforme de la droite et du sang du
Rassemblement démocratique social et
européen de liberté et territoire de la
majorité présidentielle mais aussi les
sénateurs de la majorité sénates
sénatoriale centriste et de droite alors
est-ce que c'est forcément un cadeau au
gouvernement qu'on fait les sénateurs
est-ce que le gouvernement ne va pas
apparaître comme encore plus déconnecter
de ce que pensent les Français et de ce
que ressentent les Français je suis pas
persuadé en fait que ce qui se passe au
cours des derniers jours change
fondamentalement le regard qu'ils
peuvent être amenés à réaliser dans le
cas des enquêtes qu'on que nous
produisons et que nous publions on peut
voir qu'il y a une forme de stabilité
assez grande à l'égard globalement de
l'attitude à l'égard du mouvement en
tant que tel et du fond de la réforme en
parallèle quand sur la manière dont il
perçoivent la retraite et les
différentes différents éléments qui a
une baisse des différents arguments qui
peut être portés de la part du
gouvernement que ce soit la
revalorisation maintien des pensions que
ce soit en fait le fait qu'il soit qu'il
s'agisse d'une réforme juste d'une
réforme claire donc autant d'éléments
qui globalement sont beaucoup plus
critiqués de la part de nos compatriotes
et c'est l'articulation de plusieurs
aspects 1 ce qui se passe au Parlement à
son national et Sénat ce qui se passe
dans la rue et également la
communication gouvernementale
je pense que le est-ce que c'est un
cadeau ou pas d'une manière générale je
pense que les Français enfin le fait que
le gouvernement d'Emmanuel moquerons
porte désormais un peu l'étiquette d'un
gouvernement de droite c'est gérer que
c'est déjà c'était déjà en cours
enfin bon je dirais que c'était déjà
c'était déjà un quelque chose qui était
plus ou moins
j'ai acquis en d'une certaine manière
les choses sont sont plus claires tout
simplement et encore une fois
le fait aussi que ce soit une une enfin
je dirais Emmanuel Macron est associé de
plus en plus à effectivement une forme
de de politique libérale donc je dirais
que les choses sont assez cohérentes en
fait il y a une forme de cohérence qui
est peut-être plus évidente aujourd'hui
politique on est au Sénat et au Sénat on
sait bien que balsa et à droite et que
la présence des des proches d'Emmanuel
Macron est quand même réduite à la
portion congrue en tout cas si on à la
situation à l'Assemblée nationale donc
ils sont excellent donc dans ce contexte
là c'est assez naturel que il ne soit
pas en capacité de pouvoir gérer les
débats organiser des débats et montrer
de ce que peut être la puissance et
d'ailleurs si je me trompe pas dans les
différents extraits que vous avez pu
montrer on a vu des députés en fait à
dessinateur pardon de différentes forces
politiques mais pas forcément des des
proches du président de la République
on va sur le vote de cet article cette
Jean-Daniel est-ce que ça peut renforcer
la contestation la radicaliser ou est-ce
qu'au contraire ça va l'affaiblir parce
que les gens se disent voilà c'est plié
c'est voté au Parlement ça sert plus à
rien d'aller manifester on va voir ce
qui va se passer demain il y a plusieurs
éléments qui peuvent contribuer au
maintien ou à la baisse d'une
manifestation ce qui est certain c'est
qu'il y a une connaissance qui est
encore à parfaire comme on dit parfois
publicment de nos institutions et de la
manière dont tout ceci joue et dans ce
contexte là une partie des citoyens
peuvent entendre tiens ça a été voté au
Parlement et donc dans ce contexte
est-ce que on a vraiment une utilité à
se déplacer dans le cadre d'une
mobilisation sociale donc ça c'est le
premier aspect le deuxième point
également qui est je pense important
d'avoir à l'esprit c'est que on a un
petit message qui commente à être émis
de la part des organisations et des
confédérations syndicales en disant
combien même la loi serait votée elle
n'aura pas forcément été encore
promulguée et avec on se rappelle au
moment du CPE une loi qui avait été
adoptée au Parlement mais qui n'avait
pas été promulgué à l'époque par Jacques
Chirac donc l'idée de se dire la
mobilisation pourrait éventuellement
continuer après le 29 mars c'est-à-dire
la date si je me trompe pas ultime de
vote à l'Assemblée nationale de ce que
peut être le Sénat et ça c'est une forme
de nouveautés de d'intention de
mobilisation quand bien même la loi
aurait été adoptée au Parlement
moi je sais pas s'il est effectivement
peut-être les citoyens ont une
compréhension fine ou pas de la façon
dont fonctionne et les institutions en
tout cas le processus législatif de du
noir moi je dirais surtout que
peut-être qu'il y a une intervalisation
enfin le disait en tout cas dans
certains sondages opinion du fait que la
loi peut être pourrait être votée c'est
possible mais je crois aussi que il y a
quand même dans le pays une colère on le
sait on a toujours dit qu'il y a
toujours demandé à s'exprimer qui
parfois à cette exprimé sur des sur des
sur des faits très précieux on l'a vu au
moment de à l'automne sur la question de
l'énergie donc je pense que on le voit
encore aujourd'hui il y a des soucis
bien évidemment d'un point de vue
économique de l'inflation etc donc je
pense que peut-être mal enfin la colère
va peut-être continuer à s'exprimer dans
la rue samedi nous le verrons enfin en
tout cas il y a ce climat là de fond qui
existe et qui peut-être encore se
déployer et en suivre à ça on suivra
évidemment l'examen de ce texte toute la
journée Quentin ce sera avec vous allez
on va arrêter un petit peu de parler de
réforme des retraites c'est vendredi on
va prendre un peu l'herbe c'est avec le
vendredi on vous emmène à découvrir des
traditions aujourd'hui en fait un
anniversaire suite d'une voiture qui a
marqué les Français c'est la TWING o qui
fête ses 30 ans et qui a encore des fans
et Marion Vigreux est allé en rencontrer
évidemment pour parler de leur voiture
comparer leur modèle la plus ancienne 94
et ensuite prendre la route ensemble au
volant Sophie qui possède pas moins de 7
Twingo sa voiture qui a fait partie de
mon adolescence et c'est une voiture qui
avait une très forte image sympathie
elle avait des couleurs très voyantes
très lumineuses elle était très toute
petite un vrai jouet tout le monde aime
ses voitures là tout le monde peut se
permettre et tout le monde s'en achète
une justement parce que ça lui rappelle
un moment heureux dans les années 90
des boutons sont colorés enfin c'est
vraiment une voiture qui est hyper
positive et qui est très très abordable
le petit groupe fait partie de la
communauté génération Twingo mais des
adeptes de la petite citadine il y en a
aussi à l'étranger comme au Pays-Bas
doué originaire team
de la Twingo cette voiture est trop
mignonne qu'on voulait regarder elle
vous sourit et je l'adore en fait pour
comprendre l'histoire de cette petite
bouillon plein
en mésienne
retenue comme cette 4 chevaux ou ce
Renault Espace des années 80
imaginez dès 1973 par Renault la Twingo
devait venir remplacer la 4L puis
incarnez une version compacte du
monospace c'est finalement en 1993
qu'elle voit le jour présentée comme un
véhicule bas de gamme elle doit coûter
20% moins cher qu'une voiture classique
plutôt que de faire la voiture puis
après voir combien ça coûte de la
produit on va partir de de la masse
budgétaire dont on dispose et voir ce
qu'on peut faire avec ça du coup
une seule motorisation essence pas de
moteur diesel pas de direction à droite
tant pis on va se priver des pays du
commonwell 4 couleurs seulement une
seule option le toit ouvrant autre
exemple l'antenne radio sur le
rétroviseur pour gagner en longueur de
câble il y aura trois générations de
Twingo et 14 modèles différents et très
vite ce mini format trouve son public
vendu à plus de 2,5 millions
d'exemplaires la Twingo fait aujourd'hui
partie des icônes de Renault
[Musique]
du temps parce que c'était un temps qui
était en train de changer et en fait
cette voiture se prêtait parfaitement à
des changements d'utilisation
et effectivement on a déménagé alors que
franchement c'est une petite citadine
c'est pas fait pour ça quoi mais on est
parti parfois en vacances à titre
personnel on partait à 4 sur de très
longues distances
mais c'était un peu bruyant mais c'était
pas grave on était heureux c'est
peut-être ça le point commun des fans de
cette voiture joviale
de retour de balade Sébastien lui aussi
membre du groupe génération Twingo a
sorti ses archives et à l'occasion des
essais le magazine Auto Plus à décider
d'emmener la Twingo à New York et a fait
un reportage vous voyez la la petite
Renault au côté des grandes américaines
pendant que Sophie étale ses objets
souvenirs
autant d'objets qui deviennent collector
car en soufflant ces 30 bougies Twingo
est devenu une voiture de collection
depuis 30 ans le voit toujours on la
croise beaucoup donc c'est une voiture
qui mérite parfaitement d'être d'être en
collection d'être préservé et d'être
chouchouté c'est un véhicule qui
clairement à sa place dans l'histoire et
qui restera dans l'histoire
[Musique]
Twingo à vous demander la vie qui va
avec
et voilà pour les 30 ans de la Twingo la
semaine prochaine ça vient de chez nous
emmène dans le seul étoilé Michelin de
Seine-Saint-Denis ce sera à découvrir
vendredi prochain
[Musique]